these people came from all parts of
Bangladesh to attend this
rally I came to protest the enforced
disappearances murders and oppression
that we have suffered for the past 15
years this government is not safe
anymore for even a
second at some point violence erupted
between opposition supporters and police
in different parts of the demonstration
in the capital Dhaka a policeman and an
opposition activist were killed and
hundreds of others were injured
including several journalists
thousands of opposition party members
were also arrested across the
country we couldn't even grasp what was
happening all of a sudden we came to the
rally like many other members and they
started arresting us for no
reason the main opposition Bangladesh
nationalist party has called for a
Countrywide Dawn to dust general strike
on 29 October in protest against what
they say is a police
Crackdown security has been tightened
all across the country and in the
capital Dhaka tension remains high after
the clash between opposition members and
police Security Forces often accuse
demonstrators of attacking them first
but rights groups say that many videos
and witness accounts show that
protesters are often harassed and bitten
by the police F and often with the
support of ruling party supporters I
don't think so always law enforcement
agency are for the people they are the
friend of the people so they always
maintain the Law and Order situation of
the this area and all over the
country the government party Al League
also held rallies across the country but
it warned Rivals against staging
unauthorized
demonstrations we will see who takes
shelter where and in which area without
permission you expect to hold rallies
and hide in the alleys you will not have
any Escape route we want to be clear on
this with the troubled economy and
soring cost of living Bangladesh now
faces the additional challenge of
growing unrest and calls for a change of
government ahead of general elections in
January Chri Al jazer
Dhaka make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer